alright this is a Candy Crush Soda Saga
demonstration on how to make fish. fish
changed a little bit from the original
candy
crush saga and into candy crush soda saga so
now you can make them my making a match of
four candies in a square where like here we have these three we can bring the other blue one in and
you get a fish to form. the same thing here we have yellow ones
we have one more we can bring down
and we get another fish. so the fish they
eat ice or they'll eat chocolate on chocolate boards as well
when you match two of them together you can see they turn into
3 and they'll eat three squares and let's see if we can mix them together with a striped here
when you mix them with a striped candy
they make one stripe, they take place
one stripe
whenever they eat whatever square they're going to eat
so they will send a shot one way or the other
it doesn't matter which one you match them with it is random as to which direction it will go
and you can match them with a color bomb as well
and this is a really cool one especially on a board like this
it is going to turn all the green candies
on the board into fish
so you can do that
and you can also match it with the wrapped candy and when you
do that it is going to
take out one of these ones that's over top of
a piece of ice
and then it is going to explode
to take out all the squares around it
in the general vicinity.  I'm trying to think if i can get both here
but I am just going to show you how the color bomb works
like I said this elite all those tiles
and
because that is the coolest one
so you can see that Fish are pretty
effective
special candies now
they work a lot differently than they did before so read our guide and
you'll know all about them and how to use them to get past some of the tougher levels
make sure if you have any questions to leave a comment
and like the video if you found it helpful, thanks